um let's go to our caller from the 905
area code caller from 905 who's there
hey Davey can you hear me yeah who's
this great this is Simon taxi from
Toronto Canada all the way up north in
the land of free health care school I'm
calling in because I have a kind of a
political philosophical question for you
that applies to Canada as much as
anywhere else as much as the US and all
that so I a common theme through
left-wing politics that you've talked
about and I'm pretty much agree with
this about putting regulations on
businesses to kind of make it kind of
level the playing field and one rebuttal
to this point from the right is often
that we need to make sure that we're
open for business so we want to make
sure that we don't have regulations
because then the scares business
business is away and it discourages them
from opening up shop here and starting
businesses here what's kind of your
rebuttal to that point from the right in
terms of how can we balance regulation
and also encouraging businesses to
actually come and and create jobs and
opportunities here yeah well just use
you said it the word is balance I mean
there's no there's no this is not a
black and white thing if you have no
business regulations we see what happens
you have horrible working conditions you
have people being killed by not only by
virtue of their employment at a
particular business you have products
that are unregulated services it's
horrible it's a public health crisis it
ends up having so many negative
externalities that are borne by the
people rather than the businesses so you
can't have no regulations if you over
regulate then you are going to create a
disincentive for people to even get into
a business if it's either too expensive
or the processes is too daunting or
obtrusive or whatever the case may be so
it's sort of like with taxes right I
mean if you have a 100 percent tax rate
doesn't make sense if the government
collects no taxes you can't have a
reasonably functioning society so you've
got to dial in what is the right amount
of Taxation and similarly you have to
write in dial in the right amount of
regulation I mean if the right if the
right is arguing for no regulation
that's kind of a fantasy libertarian
argument if they're in the realm of
reality then it's just
matter of where where do we place the
amount of regulation yeah I know that
definitely makes a lot of sense to me
can you actually think of any example of
an over-regulation that you've seen or
that has been ever brought up that you
think would be going too far and that
would be actually damaging
I mean anecdotally I can tell you that
there are in Argentina there are sort of
antiquated bureaucracies that are not
useful they don't increase custody you
know end-user safety in any way they
don't achieve any particular purpose and
this is sort of like a bigger problem in
Argentina there's a joke about what do
you have to do if you want to plant the
tree sort of thing but you know offhand
I mean I don't have any particular
example of a regulation that I think we
should get rid of no okay well last
quick point on this so I definitely
agree with what you're saying I think
many people on the Left do how would you
convince a business who may probably be
more on the side against that that they
know we want less regulation how would
you kind of pitch that to them so that
you can still encourage them to to come
over here and to start and open
businesses here but also it depends on
what industry they're in and whether
there's a market I mean what's going to
determine whether who am I to tell a
business owner to come and open a
business maybe it's for something
there's no market for right I mean it's
it's sort of like first of all before I
even try to convince them about anything
regarding regulations do they have a
business that would do well in my city
or do they not I mean I think there's
just so much so much needs to happen
before anyone starts trying to convince
business owners to start businesses
despite regulation it's sort of like
what do you do you even have a saleable
product or service to begin with all
right no III definitely I can definitely
see that thanks so much for your nuanced
thoughts on the topic day but that's it
for me okay great great to hear from you
I really appreciate it